I saw this movie in theaters. And again, like
what Nina said, my hair was blown back, my head
exploded. I was like, oh my God, perfect
movie. I got out of that movie and one of
the guys I saw it with was like, "I didn't
like it. It wasn't funny." And I was like-
And you killed him.
No. Yeah, and now he's dead.
So today we are
going to talk out movies that completely changed
halfway through. You know when you start
watching a movie and you think I know what
this movie's all about, and then by the time you
get to the end you go, "What did I just watch?"
And sometimes that works out really, really well
because you're like, "Whoa, that wasn't what
I expected at all." And other times you want to
flush your TV down the toilet. We're going to talk
about those movies. So Nina, what's your pick for
a movie that completely changed halfway through?
Thanks for asking, Brian.
You're welcome.
I always say that. So I'm going to pick an example
of one that I think did it perfectly. And I don't
think that this is going to be a particular really
spicy take. I think, if you've seen this movie,
and once I start talking about it we'll have
to put a spoiler warning up, if you've seen
this movie, you know what I'm talking about. So
I think it was mid 2019, maybe closer to the fall
by the time this was released where I lived, but
it was towards the end of 2019. So I go to see a
movie by myself and I was like, "I don't really
know much about this movie, but I've heard great
things. I want to check it out." And I don't know
two-ish hours later I left Parasite so stunned.
Oh, sure.
That I was like, I think I walked in a circle
for 20 minutes just being like, "Oh my God,
what did I watch? What did I watch?
What did I watch? Oh my God. Oh my God."
That's a great one. That's a great one.
I love... Yeah, again, this is not a
spicy take. Parasite is a great film.
I've watched it so many times since, and I keep
finding new things in it. And I just think it's
flawless. I think it's perfect. But I've
read a lot of stuff about how Bong Joon-ho,
a genius, structured the movie. He didn't
do a three act structure. So the spoilers,
the part where the housekeeper shows
up at the house is the exact, when the
family has overtaken the rich family's house and
they're all hanging out in there and drinking,
the housekeeper ringing the doorbell is the
exact midway point of the script itself.
Oh cool.
Which I didn't know until
he started talking about it,
because in the beginning it reminds me of a heist
movie. It's like this caper where they're like,
oh we can trick this very gullible, wealthy
family. We can get ourselves jobs. We can
infiltrate their lives. And it's kind of
perversely funny, and it has some lift to it.
You think it's going in such a direction where
their lies will be exposed, and they'll have to
cover it up, and this, that, and the other thing.
And you're like, okay, I know where this is going.
Yeah. You think you have a sense of what's going
on. And the whole Jessica from Chicago. That stuff
is kind of funny in a dark way. And then all of a
sudden you're like, is this a horror movie? And it
is, basically. I mean, it's a very intense
thriller from that point on. And I swear to God,
when I was in the theater and the woman is trying
to open that underground passage sideways. I was
like, "Oh my God, is she a demon? What's going to
happen?" I didn't know what to expect. And then
I would tell people to go see it and they'd
be like, "What's it about?" And I'd be like,
"I'm not telling you anything. You need to go into
this movie blind. You should not know anything."
So I mean, it won best picture, which made me
overjoyed. It was so well deserved. I don't think
I need to be selling anyone on that Parasite as a
good movie, but yeah, it's such an unexpected turn
because Bong Joon-ho is so, so, so good at what
he does. He's such a good storyteller. He's such
a great writer and director, and he doesn't do
anything by accident. So every single part of the
first part of that movie is so carefully preparing
you for that turn, which is magnificent. Yeah.
Set up and pay off. It's perfect. That's great.
Even just from someone saying... Yeah, set up
and payoff. The little boy says that one of
the family members smells bad or something. And
then later that all comes full circle. I mean,
I've never been so, like had my like hair
blown back by a movie in theaters in my life,
because I was just like, "Wow, I have no idea what
I just watched and I loved every second of it."
That rules. That's such a great pick.
The first viewing of that I want to
erase it. I want to eternal sunshine it
from my brain so I can watch it again.
That's awesome.
I love that movie. Yeah.
That's such a good pick. I have a couple
on here that feel in that same vein,
but I'll save them for a bit. Tom,
what's your pick for a movie that changed
halfway through that you'd like to talk about.
I was thinking about a couple
of them. One of my favorites is,
I really like Martin McDonagh movies.
Oh I love Martin McDonagh. Yeah.
Yeah. I'm not making any
big swings by saying that.
I'm ignorant. I don't even
know that name. I'm sorry.
He's written, he wrote In Bruges
with Colin Farrell, and Gleeson-
And Three Billboards.
... and Three Billboards
Outside Ebbing, Missouri. Yeah.
Okay.
And also a play that takes place in my hometown,
called A Behanding in Spokane that he wrote for
Sam Rockwell, and Christopher
Walken, and, I think, Anthony Mackie.
Oh, wow.
Yeah. Terrific. Really great. Anyway-
He's actually, primarily a playwright. A
really good playwright. Martin McDonagh. Yeah.
Yeah. He's wonderful, and weird, and
kind of dark. And in between In Bruges,
and Three Billboards he had a movie that
came out that, I don't know, people didn't
seem to pay as much attention to it. And in their
defense, the movie is firmly up its own, but it's
very... So Martin McDonagh's the guy that wrote
it. The main character is a writer named Marty
who is struggling with the fact that his movies
are not doing the things that he wants them to do.
Hmm. Interesting.
No, like there's some pretension there, but
terrific, really weird movie. And the whole
thing kind of feels like it's going to turn
into a Quentin Tarantino blood bath at the end,
but at the point where it probably should,
instead of that, the main characters
just kind of drive into the desert and camp
out for about half an hour and just talk.
It's just them talking about what should
story structure be? What should happen next.
What's it called? I don't think you've told us.
Oh, okay. Yeah. It's called
Seven Psychopaths. It's-
Oh, I like that movie.
Seven Psychopaths. Okay.
Yeah.
I've seen that.
It's really cool.
That sounds familiar. Okay.
It's got a really good. Sam Rockwell is in that
as well, right? It's got a really good cast.
Sam Rockwell. I liked him better in that
than I liked him in Three Billboards.
I agree.
He's really weird. It's a great character
for him. And Christopher Walken.
Oh yeah. It's another regular Colin Farrell. Yeah.
Yep. Totally. Yeah. Great movie. Really fun.
Seven Psychopaths. All right. I'll have to check
that out. Okay. Those are great picks. Wow. So,
so far we're picking good movies.
Well, we're smart, good people.
We're smart, good people. So
that's why we're saying these.
Let's talk about some that
maybe don't work. I have one-
right off the bat from this here
list on looper.com. It's probably one,
if you were to ask me, just point blank,
pick a movie that changes halfway through,
I'd say this first without
thinking. And it's Hancock.
Oh, all right.
Have you seen Hancock?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Not for a long time. I think when it came out.
I remember when it came out and it didn't do
very well. It got bad reviews. I was like,
oh, that's weird, because the trailers
looked pretty good. And then I saw it
when I was hanging out with a friend, it was on
VOD, or whatever, so we rented it. I was like,
"How bad could it be?" And I was like, "Oh,
real bad." It's not good. It starts off as
kind of a parody of superheroes where he
is like a crappy superhero. It's like,
what if Superman had a drinking problem.
There you go. Great premise to a movie.
Right.
It's pretty good premise. Like,
what if he was just a bum?
An SNL sketch. Yeah.
Or whatever. Right, exactly.
An SNL sketch, whatever.
Isn't it also kind of like the pre
Avengers, and the boy's thing of,
what about the damage superheroes do to cities?
Yes. Absolutely.
Because, those are both things
that really address that
in more detail now, but that
wasn't a thing for a long time.
There's so much that works in this in the
first half of this movie, where Hancock's
got these problems, he stinks, he's making all
these mistakes left and right. Jason Bateman
comes along and he is like, "I'm going
to rehabilitate your image." So you're
talking about marketing, you're talking about
branding, you're talking about consumerism
through the superhero lens, and stardom through
the superhero lens. All this great stuff. And then
halfway through the movie you find out that Jason
Bateman's wife is also a secret superhero and
they're both immortal, and they've both been alive
for thousands of years, and you're like, "What?"
It Shyamalans It's pretty hard.
What happened to this movie, because now it's
something else and it's awful. So that's one.
Why does Charlize Theron love
playing immortal characters?
Because she doesn't age?
I mean, yeah, she looks pretty much the same.
Okay. I'll accept that answer.
Is that of which you know? Yeah.
That wasn't me trying to knock Charlize Theron,
because she could knock the crap
out of me, and I love her, so.
All of us. Another good one on here is From
Dusk Till Dawn. Have you guys seen that one?
Obvious choice.
Such a weird turn.
Early in George Clooney's movie career.
I remember watching this movie. It was on
Stars or something when I was in high school.
It was on stars a lot. I feel like.
I was watching it and the first half is this
awesome, like crime caper, like George Clooney
and Quentin Tarantino take this family hostage.
They're trying to get out of town, or whatever,
and then halfway through vampires show up, and
it's a vampire monster movie, and it's insane. And
again, I would even say that both of those movies
are pretty okay. But stuck together, you're kind
of like, "Do I want this? I would rather see one
of these movies have a beginning, middle and end."
But was it... It feels like the precursor
to the Death Proof, and what was the other?
When it was the two movies that
Tarantino and Robert Rodriguez did.
Yeah. Planet Terror.
Grindhouse.
Planet Terror. Thank you. Yeah. Grindhouse. Thank
you. I was really blanking on those, but yeah,
those are two separate things and they're stuck
together, but you know they're supposed to be.
I'm not saying they're perfect,
but they know what they are.
I liked both.
I liked From Dusk Till Dawn. I'm all in favor
of the weirdness. Yeah. And Planet Terror was-
I remember that first half
being really good. So I think I was more just
annoyed that I didn't get to see the resolution
of the movie I started. But I'm sure if I
revisit it today I'd probably share your opinion,
because I don't remember it being bad. I was
mostly just baffled by, there's this one part,
I don't think we can show this, but I'll just
describe it. We'll probably censor it. But there's
one part where a vampire's playing electric
guitar with a dead body that's naked or something-
... I seem to remember. Some insane
thing. So I just remember that being
a very heavy contrast with what had come
before, and in a way, that baffled me.
I don't think Robert Rodriguez is
the subtlest director in the world.
You mean the guy who did Spy Kids is not subtle?
Yeah.
What are you trying to say?
I think maybe he loves himself some camp.
Yeah, a little bit.
Some good old fashioned camp. So I mean, I'm going
to side with Tom a little more here, in that
I think that movie knows that it's
insane, and that's kind of the pleasure of it.
I need to revisit it, but
I think it's a good choice.
I think it does. Yeah. It's a really good
choice, because the first time you watch it,
you're like, "What?" But I think it's more self
aware that I'm probably remembering, because
I think Rodriguez is very aware of
what he's doing a lot of the time.
Fantastic practical effects in that movie. Tom
Savini, one of the kind of godfathers of practical
effects is in it as one of the patrons at the
vampire bar. And he's the one that's got the,
speaking of things that we would have to censor,
he's got the belt buckle gun that flips open.
Love it.
Then it also shows up in Desperado.
Oh, right. I forgot about that.
Good night.
I have two more picks for this one. Not from this
article, unfortunately, but one I just mentioned
in a recent video, is a movie adaptation
where the first half of the movie is this...
It's very similar to what you discussed, what you
described in Seven Psychopaths, where it's a movie
about a writer, written by Charlie Kaufman,
starring Nicholas Cage as Charlie Kaufman,
trying to write the movie that you are watching.
And the whole first half just goes in circles.
Nothing happens. Any event that happens is not
actually contributing to the story moving forward,
it's just stuff happening. And then halfway
through his dumb twin brother, Donald,
writes the rest of the movie like a typical
Hollywood box checking movie that Charlie
specifically said he didn't want it to become. And
it does perfectly. And it's great. So that's one.
I love that movie.
The other one is another favorite of
mine. It is a movie called Hot Fuzz.
Great choice.
And the reason I bring it up is because...
Oh, great choice.
Great choice. Great choice.
I saw this in theaters. I saw this movie in
theaters, and again, like what Nina said,
my hair was blown back, my head exploded.
I was like, "Oh my God. Perfect movie.
Perfection." I got out of that movie and
one of the guys I saw it with was like,
"I didn't like it. It wasn't
funny." And I was like-
And you killed him.
No. Yeah, and now he's dead. But that's because
the whole first half of the movie is the setup,
and the whole second half, or at least whenever
that cut is when it turns into an action movie is
the payoff. It set up our punchline even. It's
one joke, but the first half of the joke is an
hour long, and the punchline is a half an hour.
It's what if we make a joke about action movies,
and then that's the punchline at the
end. It's just like, the turn is perfect.
Everything is just so funny. It's so good. And
it is, it's like you're watching two different
movies, because one is a silly, goofy parody
of cop dramas that is very light on action,
but making jokes about it. And then the second
part is all the action that you wanted from the
first part and as funny as possible, in a small
town in England. It's one of the best movies
ever made. It's one of the best movies
ever made. There, I said it. Hot Fuzz.
Yeah. Another really, really spicy take that
Hot Fuzz is a good movie, actually like, "Whoa."
Yeah. Deal with that.
Going to break the internet.
No, it's funny you bring up a Hot Fuzz, because as
we were talking, I recently watched, this is super
recent. I'll try to keep it relatively spoiler
free. But I watched Last Night in Soho recently,
which I mostly enjoyed. I think it's really
ambitious, and I love that about it. I don't
think it quite sticks the landing, but
that's its own thing. But it really-
Which you mention because it's
also an Edgar Wright movie.
Yes. Sorry.
Yeah. That's where the
train of my brain was going.
There's the connection.
Yes. And so I just watched
that. I love Edgar Wright.
I'm a huge fan. I mean another super hot take.
Wow. Just crushing it today. And so I was really
excited to see Last Night in Soho, because I love
him, and I love Anya Taylor-Joy, and all that
stuff. But the first half is this very glamorous
period piece set in the 1960s in London, and
it's glitzy, and then all of a sudden it kind of
descends into just absolute horror. And it doesn't
really prepare you for that. And like I said,
it kind of works up until, I deeply respect that
Wright just really went for it in this movie. And
I'm going to leave you guys to watch it, because
I think I'm the only one here who has, but-
I've got to check it out. It's on my list.
... he is typically, Hot Fuzz
is a perfect example of that,
where he takes a huge leap and it so
works. It couldn't work better. And
so, I mean, that's what's so great about him is,
he's one of the only directors willing to be like,
let's try this really crazy turn in this
movie and see if we can pull it off.
Yeah.
It works great. It works great.
Thanks for watching. Please
hit like, and subscribe.